THAT THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION IS
NOT WHAT THEY SAID IT WAS.
IT IS THAT HAS BEEN FROM THE
BEGINNING BEEN A WITCH HUNT.
TOM HAS BEEN HAS BEEN TRACKING
THE INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE VERY
FIRST DAY AND HE'S ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL WATCH AND
HE JOINS US NOW.
TOM, IS THAT AN UNFAIR SUMMARY
OF WHAT WE LEARNED?
HAVE I MISSED SOMETHING?
HAVE WE GOTTEN ANY INDICATION OF
ACTUAL COLLUSION A YEAR INTO
THIS?
>> NO WE HAVEN'T.
YOU'VE BEEN MUCH TOO CHARITABLE.
IF HONESTLY EVALUATED, THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
IF THE MEDIA WERE COVERING THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION THE WAY IT
WAS COVERING THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY I THINK WE WOULD ALL
AGREE IT HASN'T WORKED.
IT'S FAILING.
IT WAS CREATED BASED ON AN
ILLEGAL LEAK BY JAMES COMEY.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO INSPIRE
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WERE
FIRED FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
SALLY EIGHTS, THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ANDREW McCABE, THE DEPUTY AG.
JAMES COMEY, THE FBI DIRECTOR.
ANDREW McCABE, EXCUSE ME THE
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR.
ALL THREE FIRED FOR MISCONDUCT.
THEY HELP GET THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WILL IMPAIRED THE
CLINTON EMAIL DOSSIER.
WE HAVE THE FLYNN INVESTIGATION
UNDER ATTACK BECAUSE OF THE
CORRUPT WAY WHICH IT WAS
INITIATED AND INVESTIGATED BY
THE FBI WERE HIT THEY THAT HE
LIED WHEN EVIDENTLY HE DIDN'T.
AND ON TOP OF THAT WE GOT A
FEDERAL JUDGE QUESTIONING THE
ULTIMATE AUTHORITY OF
MR. MUELLER AND WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WHAT HIS AUTHORITY IS A
YEAR OUT BECAUSE HE HAS
EVIDENTLY HAD SECRET
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND ON TOP OF IT, THE RUSSIA,
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION, THE
KEY ASPECT OF IT, THE RUSSIA
TROLL INDICTMENT, IT'S NOW BEING
TURNED INTO WHEN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE TO GO
IN AND DEMAND EVIDENCE FOR WHAT
THEY HAVE ON INTELLIGENCE
OPERATIONS, MAINLY INTERVENTION
IN ORDER ELECTION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
VICTIMIZED THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
EVIDENTLY THERE'S NOTHING TO
JUSTIFY AN INVESTIGATION OF HIM
REQUIRING JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
RESOURCES.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT --
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, THE
WHOLE POINT OF THE INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL IS TO ENSURE THE REST OF
US THAT THE INVESTIGATION IS ON
THE LEVEL, NOT TAINTED BY
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS.
GIVEN THAT, WHY DIDN'T MUELLER
TRY HARDER TO AT LEAST SEEN BY
PART OF BIPARTISAN, MAYBE HIRING
ONE REGISTER OF REPUBLICAN AS
INVESTIGATOR, HE DIDN'T BOTHER
TO DO THAT.
>> THE ARROGANCE OF THE DEEP
STATE.
THEY THINK THEY CAN DO NO WRONG.
MUELLER AND COMEY ARE PART OF
THE SAME TEAM ON THAT REGARD.
ON TOP OF THAT YOU HAVE THEM
HIRING DEMOCRATS WITH ABANDON
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE TEXT
MESSAGES.
HE KEPT THOSE TWO FBI AGENTS OFF
OF HIS INVESTIGATION BECAUSE OF
BIAS AND HID THAT FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR FOUR MONTHS.
MR. COMEY, IF YOU ARE A TYPICAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL WOULD HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO RESIGN A LONG TIME
AGO.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD POINT.
TOM FITTON, FOLLOWING THIS FROM
DAY ONE, THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Tucker: IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S FOR
LUNCH IS STILL MUCH WHAT WAS
FOCUS ON RUSSIA COLLUSION MAY
HAVE BEEN A MISTAKE POLITICALLY.
AN ARTICLE THIS MORNING IN
"THE DAILY BEAST" MAKES A
LUDICROUS CLAIM.
IT SAYS THAT DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
WANTED TO SPEND THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF TALKING ABOUT REAL
ISSUES, HEALTH CARE AND THE
ECONOMY, BUT THEY COULDN'T
SOMEHOW BECAUSE CABLE NEWS STOPS
THEM.
RACHEL MADDOW TOLD THEM NOT TO
APPARENTLY.
CABLE INSTEAD FORCED THEM TO
TALK ABOUT RUSSIA.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO.
LUCKILY WE KEPT COPIES OF THE
TAPE AND HERE'S WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY SAID ABOUT RUSSIA.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
RUSSIA ATTACKED US.
>> ATTACK ON THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTIONS.
>> AN ATTACK ON OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> WE ARE ONLY AT THE BEGINNING
OF UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
RUSSIANS DID TO AFFECT OUR
ELECTIONS.
>> I THINK THERE IS A BROAD
RECOGNITION AMONG OUR MEMBERS
THAT RUSSIA IS NOT OUR FRIEND.
>> WHY DOES AN OUTWARD
DONALD TRUMP THAT THE RUSSIANS
ACCORDING TO THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY TRIED TO, AND INDEED
DID KIND OF INFILTRATE AND
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY BY WHAT
THEY DID?
>> Tucker: RICHARD GOODSTEIN
IS A LAWYER, HE ADVISED BOTH OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGNS AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT FOR WHAT'S GOING TO BE A
TOUGH CONVERSATION I   FOR HIM I
WOULD SAY.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT REALLY
POSSIBLE TO MAKE THE CASE -- YOU
CAN ARGUE THAT RUSSIA HACKED OUR
ELECTION AS DEMOCRATS HAVE
ARGUED FOR THE LAST YEAR.
THEY ARE OUR MAIN ENEMY IN THE
WORLD AS THEY ALSO ARGUE.
MAYBE TIME WILL PROVE YOU'RE
RIGHT.
I DOUBT IT BUT MAY BE.
YOU CAN'T ARGUE IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT THAT WHAT YOU REALLY
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WAS THE
ISSUES.
IF YOU DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO
TALK ABOUT RUSSIA, YOU JUST
HAPPEN TO TALK ABOUT IT NONSTOP
FOR A YEAR.
NOBODY'S GOING TO BELIEVE THAT
BECAUSE IT'S A LIE.
>> IF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, NOT DEMOCRATS, NOT
REPUBLICANS.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS
THE GROUP THAT SAID THAT THE
RUSSIANS TRY TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY.
DON'T LAY THAT OFF ON ME.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NO
INTELLIGENCE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER A FEDERAL
AGENCIES, THERE IS NO
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THERE IS NO CONSENSUS ON
ANYTHING.
>> THERE'S A DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
HEAD OF CIA.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO IS
CHARGED WITH OVERSEEING
INTELLIGENCE FOR THIS COUNTRY
WHEN ASKED AND WHEN THEIR AGENCY
WAS ASKS THAT THE RUSSIANS TRY
TO INTERFERE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE
RUSSIANS APPROACHED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND SAID WE HAVE STOLEN
MATERIALS, WOULD YOU LIKE THEM
FROM THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
DONALD TRUMP JR. SAID LOVE IT.
PUTTING ASIDE WHAT ULTIMATELY
HAPPENED LATER --
>> Tucker: I WOULD SAY WE
FILED THIS GROUND BEFORE.
WHAT I'M ASKING WAS A POLITICAL
QUESTION.
CLEARLY THIS IS NOT BEARING
FRUIT FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEIR LEAD IS WITHIN A MARGIN OF
ERROR.
IT'S JUST NOT WORKING.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO RETAKE
CONGRESS ON THE STRENGTH OF THE
RUSSIA STORY.
AND NOW THEY'RE TELLING US WE
NEVER WANTED TO ABOUT RUSSIA IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND ALL I'M
SAYING IS THAT'S A LIE.
DON'T LIE TO ME WHEN I'VE BEEN
WATCHING TV FOR THE PAST YEAR
AND ALL YOU TALKED ABOUT HIS
RUSSIA.
DID RACHEL MADDOW MAKE YOU DO
THAT?
DON'T LIE TO ME.
>> THE FACT IS I THINK THERE'S
TWO TRACKS.
I THINK THE FACT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY KNOWS IT'S NOT
GOING TO WIN THIS ELECTION.
THEY WILL NOT WIN THE 2018
ELECTIONS JUST TALK ABOUT
MUELLER OR TRUMP EVEN.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN AFFIRMATIVE
AGENDA ABOUT ECONOMIC JUSTICE
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
DONALD TRUMP -- WE USED TO SAY
YOU HAD HISTORICALLY LOW
APPROVAL RATINGS.
I CHECKED TODAY, JIMMY CARTER
ACTUALLY EDGED THEM OUT SO HE'S
NOW SECOND MOST UNPOPULAR
PRESIDENT THIS FAR INTO IT.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
>> EVERY ELECTION -- WE JUST HAD
THAT SPECIAL ELECTION IN
ARIZONA.
TRUMP WON BY 21, THE REPUBLICAN
WON BY FIVE.
EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN WON THE
HOUSE LAST YEAR BY 16 POINTS OR
UNDER HAS TO BE LOOKING OVER
THEIR SHOULDER SCARED TO DEATH
BECAUSE THIS MOMENTUM.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS HAVE A
LOT OF ENERGY.
IT'S A MIDTERM IN THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST TERM.
OF COURSE THEY ARE GOING TO GAIN
SEATS.
THERE HAVE ONLY BEEN I THINK TO
ELECTIONS IN AMERICAN HISTORY
WHEN THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN, BUT
DEMOCRATS DON'T LOOK LIKE THEY
ARE A LOCK TO WIN THAT THE
AMERICAN HOUSE.
HALF THE COUNTRY IS LIKE HIM.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE WAY FAR
AHEAD OF WHERE THEY ARE TODAY.
THE REASON THEY ARE NOT FARTHER
AHEAD IS BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
RUNNING ON EVERYTHING.
THEY ARE RUNNING ON THINGS LIKE
MORE ABORTION AND MORE ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
THAT'S INSANE AND IT SCARES
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW THAT.
>> WE WILL SEE WHEN THE 2018
MIDTERMS ROLLED AROUND.
ALL WE KNOW IS FROM EVERY OTHER
SINGLE SPECIAL ELECTION THE
DEMOCRATIC WAVE SEEMS TO BE ON
THE ORDER OF TEN, 15%.
YOU CAN SAY WHAT YOU WANT AT
THIS POINT, THAT WILL TAKE OUT A
LOT OF INCUMBENT REPUBLICANS.
WILL IT CONTINUE?
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> Tucker: JUST FOR THE SAKE
OF HONESTY, WILL YOU CONCEDE THE
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T SPEND THE LAST
YEAR TELLING US THAT RUSSIA
HACKED OUR ELECTIONS, WHATEVER
THAT MEANS, IT WAS A LIE.
BUT THEY DIDN'T SAY THAT BECAUSE
RACHEL MADDOW MADE THEM FOR
MORNING JOE SENT THEM A MEMO AND
THEY HAD TO OBEY.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT
WOULD WORK AND IT DIDN'T.
>> THEY WERE HORRIFIED -- THAT
THE REPUBLICANS DID THIS AND
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
INDIFFERENT OR WORSE WAS
COMPLICIT.
THAT'S THE THING THAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
IF THEY CARED ABOUT THE COUNTRY
THEY WOULD SECURE THE BORDERS
AND FIGHT BACK AGAINST CHINA.
THE COUNTRIES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
CONTROLLING OUR POLICY.
NO PUSHBACK FROM THE DEMOCRATS
AT ALL BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE.
>> WE HAD A NET OUTFLOW FROM
U.S. TO MEXICO.
THE LAST FOUR OR FIVE YEARS OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WE HAD
A NET OUTFLOW.
THAT'S HOW MUCH THEY CARE ABOUT